okay all right good morning everyone
today we will focus entirely on
Revenue estimates and hopefully we can
make some decisions along the way we do
have a couple of presentations to help
us get better informed first on the
docket is James Gary is that husband uh
yeah
all right
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee my name is James Gary and
I am the state budget director I am here
to present the governor's Revenue
projections for fiscal year 24 and
fiscal year 25 for our budget of course
in order to do that we first have to
project the remaining five months of
revenues for fiscal year 23. so I'm
going to begin talking about the
remainder of fiscal year 23 and then get
into the numbers for the upcoming
biennium
I'm often asked how you come up with
your numbers for Revenue projections did
you use a particular model did you use a
straight line or moving average did you
use a simple linear regression or a
multiple linear regression
well I can answer all those put all
those questions to bed and answer for
those today how we came up with our
stalling may be a bit of a harsh word
understanding like in the old days when
someone would steal someone else's music
it was theft now it's called sampling so
in that line we sampled the dra Lottery
liquor safety and fishing game revenues
and this was really a team effort a team
theft between myself and administrative
Services together we put together these
the these forecasts and then presented
to the to the governor who signed off on
them
uh and the reason we did that is because
from the outset we realized no matter uh
how good we think we are at projecting
revenues or knowing these uh taxes
inside and out we are not better than
the people who deal with them on a
day-to-day basis therefore
we relied on the Departments and their
expertise to provide the revenue
forecasts and then we put them through a
reasonability filter to see if they made
sense and we did not just begrudgingly
accept their numbers we agree with their
numbers they were reasonable and believe
they can and should be defended
when commissioner stepp of the dra who's
here today
uh started off with testimony in front
of the committee I believe she said uh
and caution you that these numbers are
wrong I concur her numbers and the
numbers I'm presenting to hear to hear
to you today are most certainly wrong I
say that because they always are and
when I say always I mean always
before I joined the dra my past life was
as a Municipal Credit analyst and for
over 30 years I've reviewed thousands
tens of thousands of Revenue projections
for States cities towns School District
toll roads and other special Revenue
projects and they all have one thing in
common they were wrong every single one
of them I say this to emphasize the
point that we as a team and myself
sitting here here before you today do
not have a crystal ball that we can
actually predict the future I can't we
can't
what I can say is that from the day our
numbers stop moving which was pretty
much about January 31st of this year
they were the most reasonable numbers
that we could develop based on the
information we had at the time and I
want to emphasize the phrase information
we had at the time Revenue projections
like this should constantly be updated
the first Revenue projections that I was
involved with happened last July and
they have changed dramatically and
significantly from that date
now to properly properly estimate
revenues you you need two basic things
one is a historical knowledge of how
revenues react given certain changes now
given certain predictable events the
other is info information flow over time
the uh the forecast we put together for
this Budget on January 31st is
significantly better than the one we put
together in July and the reason of that
is obviously we had six months of
revenues already in the books instead of
projecting 12 months of Revenue we only
had to project six that's much easier of
course extrapolating that point further
out a forecast done in April will be
more accurate than when I have before
you today
I think it's vital that over the next
few months as you quickly wrap up your
projections then the Senate gets there
is that we all work together uh to
update these revenues continuously so
we're all working with the same
information and better information as
time goes on
now this were 2015 or 2019 I might not
be as concerned about the day-to-day
information although it's always helpful
however we are living in economic and
financially volatile times
looking back over the last eight budgets
I can give you a little sense in how the
state general fund and education trust
fund compared to plan
in 2016 we were seven our revenues were
seven percent over planned in 2017 four
percent in 2018 5.3 percent in 2019
seven percent so mid single digit
increases over plan then covet hit
in 2020 our revenues were 5.5 percent
under plan
in 2021 11.6 over plan
2022 15.4 percent over plan and through
this first six months of 2023 fiscal
year 21.2 percent over plan so things
things have changed clearly the covet
pandemic has caused typical Revenue
forecasts that were made at the
beginning of 2020 to become irrelevant
they were not wrong at the time things
changed and that's my caution to you is
is to
to the extent possible recognize these
changing these changes and the changes
are obviously not just things that
happen in New Hampshire but but on a
worldwide stage uh there there were two
things I could think about the top of my
head that could over the next few months
that could have a dramatic impact on
revenues uh the the first is the war in
Ukraine and that war were to end today
the conventional wisdom is that it would
be a very po it would have a very
positive impact on the U.S economy and
therefore the New Hampshire economy
Russian gas and oil would start flowing
again Lower fuel prices mean lower
inflation lower inflation should lead to
lower interest rates uh and that's
obviously more money uh in the pockets
of New Hampshire residents conversely
there is a question of increase in the
debt limit in Washington which will
happen in July the conventional wisdom
there is it that the debt limit is not
increased it would have a dramatic and
negative impact on the economy uh I
think looking at both uh are either
likely to happen no but they are things
that we need to keep a uh your our eye
on
it's okay so after this long-winded
response as to all the ways we could and
probably are wrong I will tell you why
we're right
I guess that you turn to the
presentation that was handed out at the
beginning uh I promise to go through
these Pages quickly because I know
you've heard these numbers before
on the second page of the presentation
you'll see the full projection of
general and education trust fund
revenues well I will discuss the
individual taxes that make up these fund
I want to make a few observations here
first we are projecting 2023 will end
with General and education fund revenues
equal to
3.1578 billion dollars this represents a
2.4 percent decline for fiscal year 22.
in fiscal year 24 we are projecting a
0.13 increase in revenues from these
funds and this includes no Revenue
coming from the communications tax which
I'll explain a little later on the
presentation
I mean in 2025 we see another 0.76
percent decline in projected revenues
however the numbers in the budget and
the percentage changes that I just gave
you are a bit misleading because of the
one-year 100 million dollar reduction in
the amount of sweat taxes collected in
2023 100 million dollars less swept tax
was collected than is going to be
collected in 2024 or 2022. it will
increase uh back to its original a
traditional 363 million dollar level
when you look at the total year-to-year
change while excluding swept revenues
are estimated to decline 3.31 percent in
24 and an additional 0.86 and 25. so uh
the overall change from 2022 to 2025
will see a decline in revenues of about
three percent
if you were to add back in the
communications tax revenue the clock
decline is still real it's but it's a
slightly less at 2.1 percent
one thing I hear and I'm asked about uh
constantly is given the strong economy
that we've had and record-setting
revenues should the decrease actually be
larger
perhaps however I ask you to look at the
economic data and the economic data has
been erratic
but over the last four quarters the
growth in the U.S economy as measured by
GDP has been as follows negative 0.16
negative 0.6 3.2 and 2.9 percent that's
an average growth rate of less than one
percent yet produce record-setting
revenues that is hardly an economy on
fire
so while the future as I mentioned my
opening is volatile and unpredictable
there is still room for growth however
we believe that while that possibility
exists we are taking a more cautious
approach by predicting a slight decline
over the biennium
now if you turn to page three you will
see how the revenue projections
presented in the governor's budget
differs from the revenue projections the
various departments have given you
on this and the pages that fall I'm
going to talk about the revenue
projection streams where our forecast is
either High higher or significantly
different than those of the Departments
most of the differences come about as a
result of timing our numbers stop moving
the day before theirs did or or before
theirs did so almost always the
Departments will have better information
than the numbers that I gave you
looking on page three you'll see the
first one that's there and is
highlighted in red if it's in if it's in
green that means that we are at or below
the range given by the Departments red
means we're higher so looking at page
three you see that the Liquor Commission
is highlighted in red
the reason for the difference uh is is
is not really a timing issue is just
with the assumptions that that they used
uh their number includes a transfer to
HHS
so if you back out that transfer our
numbers are the same
so we will uh we will firm that up with
uh with staff and make sure we get the
right number but we we have confidence
that our number you know without
including that transfer is the correct
number
uh the insurance tax this is a timing
issue we were one million dollars or
point seven one percent higher than
Insurance uh again they have the best
and latest information and I would
adjust our numbers to match theirs their
number is the controlling number
and that brings us to the real estate
transfer tax
this is the one that I worry about the
most
at the end of December the real estate
transfer track tax was projected to
bring in about 250
sure
mine's okay
yep
hello yeah all right I think we're back
up how about on your side representative
fellows we have okay good all right so
this is fascinating and everything
you're saying I'm taking copious notes
but in some cases we might need to slow
you down if that's okay because we have
questions along the way I saw a hand
on the uh you started on this page with
the governor's estimates compared with
the Department estimates I uh
um
so I think we're on that page with the
green and the red and um I wondered uh
take the first one the business uh taxes
you've got one two five seven for the
Governor's estimates in the department
the same number
but in the Department's case that's the
high that is the highest of their high
and low
so my question is why are you taking
taking the high of uh of dra's estimates
I think you do that consistently we we
do do that consistently and uh the main
reason is we're very optimistic about
the the the the underlying economy in
New Hampshire uh we have seen a number
of businesses move into New Hampshire uh
demand for basic uh goods and services
remains very strong uh the housing
market which I'm about to get into while
off from last year is still strong even
though it's a plus or minus it has
pluses and minuses uh there is a strong
demand for housing in New Hampshire and
that continues and we believe that the
uh the the business climate of of
businesses uh especially Massachusetts
businesses moving to New Hampshire is
going to continue
so so that's why we are on the
optimistic side of of their range Madam
chair representative Southworth uh thank
you for taking my question is it similar
for number two that you're optimistic
about that industry uh meals and rentals
yes absolutely with meals and rentals
one of the things we saw which after the
pandemic and the restaurants opened up
we saw meals and Rental Stacks Skyrocket
and
um with that uh you know the feeling was
maybe it was just pent-up demand that
people just wanted to get out of the
house and started to go and uh as we've
seen over the over the over the last uh
over the last year and especially over
the last few months is that the mules
and Rental sex continues to be very
strong and one of the things to keep in
mind is there a lot of restaurants are
doing this despite decreased hours the
work shortages is real a lot of
restaurants have had to cut back on
hours and they're still producing record
revenues and we believe that when the
workforce uh comes back in line that uh
we're going to see even higher revenues
from them I'm with clarification
um have you found um that it is still
uneven around the whole state like I'm
in the Seacoast and I agree it's booming
but I'm not sure it is everywhere
uh that's possible if if uh we have
someone in the room who maybe have a
better answer that but uh I mean we've
seen strong growth throughout the state
but certain Pockets have
uh Stronger uh projections than others
but
representative Army
thank you
on
I think before the reduction from the
what the ra estimated last time would be
the cost of the tax changes that have
been made in the past
yeah we we have taken those into account
as well
did you take you take to account in in
this and which is I think the same as
your executive budget summary yes we did
not not for business taxes well for yes
for business taxes we did we we followed
you've uh
we'll have crochet help us prepare
things too
representative Platt yes
in any of these projections did you
assume
a possibility of a recession how
possible when and how did it affect your
numbers uh we did in our and and if you
remember I uh mentioned that our first
estimate we did was in July and it
varies dramatically from what we did now
and that we were thinking it was a
recession and if you look at the the
economic data and economic opinion it's
really flip-flopped almost 180 degrees
because what you have is in in July
about three quarters of economists were
predicting a recession
and now about three quarters of
economists are not predicting a
recession they believe that we're going
to have that soft Landing which is the
the goal of uh certainly was the goal of
the Treasury Department and and the FED
when they started raising interest rates
and I think as we've seen uh in
inflation start to come down the need to
increase interest rates additionally is
going to wane and so we do not believe
currently that while we may have an
economic slowdown nationally that that
will be caused by a degree of factors We
Believe again that the New Hampshire uh
economy is one where it'll it could be
immune to uh like a national slowdown
and one of the main reasons is housing
and what we've seen from other states
especially in the South and the West as
far as housing goes is that you have a
lot of housing there that was built
speculatively uh which is the when we
got into the problem in 2007 and 2008
that was the main driver of that but in
New Hampshire we have such a pent-up
demand for housing our vacancy rate is
still next to zero and and while the
housing on the uh wait list has
certainly
improved from a buyer's standpoint it's
still very strong
so we did but we are not predicting a
projecting a recession and with these
numbers
other questions at this time
representative fellows
um can you just
um tell me about the meals and rooms tax
because I remember that we dropped it to
eight and a half percent was that is
that permanent or does it bounce back up
to nine no that's a permanent reduction
okay thanks
okay well you continue thank you okay
um yeah we were on the subject of what
keeps me up at night and that's the real
estate transfer tax
um at the end of December real estate
transfer tracks uh if you extrapolate it
to the end of the year was projected to
bring in about 250 million dollars of
Revenue
uh I pr our projection I believe at that
time the dras projection or at least it
really was an estimate at that point was
roughly around 243 million
however after our numbers stopped moving
uh we got the January revenue report and
saw that while the real estate transfer
tax had a strong month historically
and was above plan uh the January figure
was a shocking 37.2 percent below the
same month in 22. uh that certainly got
our attention
and my understanding is the February
numbers are again above plan but below
2022 numbers although at a much smaller
at a much smaller rate uh as as
commissioner stat pointed out in her
testimony the January in February
traditionally weak housing months uh so
when you compare it to the force that
was the beginning of 2022 that they're
not as strong but these are some of they
will be some of the uh strongest January
and February numbers we have on record
in addition the uncertainty over Rising
interest rates and almost almost
certainly played a role as we all as we
know all too well despite housing uh in
New Hampshire remaining in demand in the
Outlook while still bright our forecast
has dimmed uh in the week since our
numbers were released and based on the
latest information we have we now concur
with the dras and commissioner steps
forecasts of 227 million again this is
something a number to keep your eye on
because if there's if there's one
Revenue Source that's going to be the
most volatile in this in my opinion it's
going to be the real estate transfer
attacks
uh the other category you see there uh
we had projected a 97 million and as of
last week the projection was 111 million
I believe that was uh due to some
miscommunication uh the 111 million was
due to some miscommunication and that
number has now been revised there was
some double counting going on and that
number has now been revised to 97
million
uh so
I think he's referring to the other
right under beer tax the other category
yeah that's the one Chris emailed us
about it's like a double County thing
okay
okay and the final number uh that's in
red there is the utility property tax
utility property tax is a 6.6 tax on the
full market value of the utility being
assessed increased profitability means
increased assessed values uh
therefore I was hopeful uh that upt
would increase more uh however I had to
remind myself and to keep in mind that
the effective date of this of this
assessed valuations and therefore the
utility property tax while it's
certified on December 15th the values go
back to April 1st of 22. so the values
that we produce the tax on go back prior
to large rate increases that we've all
been subject to from the utility
companies uh therefore the the dra
figure or the dra range for the utility
property tax should be the operative one
however uh going forward and I'll talk
about this in a minute uh I'm I'm more
and more confident in our numbers that
the utility property tax will see
increases in in 24 and 25.
and and finally recoveries is also one
that's that's a little different and
that that's where actually we're under
and the Medicaid recoveries we had is
1.8 million in Health and Human Services
has a 2.6 million uh 1.8 million is
wrong uh I would go with the the
estimate of 2.6 million given by HHS
now uh when you look at the projected
revenues as a whole for 23 you'll see
that well we differ slightly on some
taxes even with these changes our
revenues are 3.157 billion or just 0.74
lower than the agency estimates
now turning to page four
uh we'll you'll see the big n a there
next sorry could we interrupt for one
ABS absolutely
okay and I'll I'll highlight the ones
the change ribs in a fellow just a
reminder to turn your mic on so we can
hear your question thank you so much
okay The Liquor Commission Revenue I
believe that uh our figure of 135
million is the controlling figure
for the insurance tax
the Department's estimate of 139 million
is the controlling figure
that's that's the number we that I'm we
are now going with yeah so they're now
revising from what they started with so
we'll take that into account in our
discussions the real estate transfer tax
of 227 million the dra estimate is the
one I would go with
uh in the other category the 97 million
that we provided with is the one I
and the utility property tax the 46.3
million that the dra provided is the one
I think you should go with
and finally recoveries
the HHS test submit of 2.6 million is
representative janigan has a question
thank you madam chair just uh quickly
the so the bottom number where you said
the total change is 0.74 so have you
figured out what the uh that updated
number is based on these changes uh I
have not but I can get that to you
I have my calculator here I can get it
from real fast
okay okay go ahead on page four you see
the communications tax
um the the dra for 2024 is projecting I
believe 29.9 million at the high end of
their range
and uh if
uh our our number before
we uh before the governor decided to
eliminate that tax was was 28 million
for for that purpose if you go that
route but I just want to talk a little
bit about the seven percent uh
Communications tax it's a seven percent
tax on two-way Communications it's
traditional cell phones landlines uh
cell phones phone calls things like that
uh
Revenue collected from the
communications tax was 72 million
dollars in 2012.
this year that'll be down to 29 million
in 2023. it's really a dying tax
and the reason why is because the nature
of communication has changed
dramatically it does not tax texting or
calls made through apps such as if you
if you FaceTime someone if you use
WhatsApp or any number of the other apps
you can use to make phone calls air
knocks taxed but if you make a phone
call you are
and we found we find this to be a very
regressive tax that impacts those who
can't afford unlimited data plans I mean
I I don't I I get maybe one or two phone
calls a month from my two sons but I
hear from them about 10 times a day
because they're always texting uh you
may have similar similar things going on
or you're probably texting all the time
too well before that you made phone
calls and you got taxed which is why the
revenue has fallen so dramatically and
again the people who uh who can't afford
unlimited data plans you know find it
cheaper to actually make the phone calls
and they're the ones being taxed so and
we we saw while it's coming down from
2012 really covid
uh changed it because it really changed
it for the business Community as well uh
before you get on a conference call
now you go on teams or or some other
video service where you you can make
phone calls or or a video conference
call through those measures those are
not taxed
so that is uh the regressive effect that
the revenues from it are dying uh have
decreased dramatically and the fact it's
a regressive tax is is why the governor
is proposing that but again our figure
which we believe will continue to go
down is 28 million uh if you want a
number from us to put it in
representative Platt has a question a
mechanical question
assuming the governor proposal gets
passed into law don't we still have to
reflect the number here and then take it
out in sb2 or something like that
because it may not be passed into law
um yeah which is why that's I think
so represent Platt
you're going to provide your estimates
which will then go down to finance
committee and in house bill one there'll
be an amendment to the unrestricted
revenues in there that will adjust for
whatever your Revenue estimates are
that's what I thought thank you for
confirming
and so our estimate is uh for fiscal
year 24 is is 28 million dollars which
um looking here
is
actually almost at the low end of the
why 25
fy25
um it's we held it flat at 28 million as
well
okay
representative almie has a question
thank you on
what is your thinking on the fact that
in 24 is the first time we're going to
see the single sales Factor controlling
um again what we did was I guess we have
the impact it will have on it on
revenues or
um
I I think I I'm going to defer to
commissioner step on that if she has a a
uh an idea I honestly say we did not
factor that in significantly and as a as
a moving as a major impact on on our
numbers but I don't know if you
have anything I'm sorry I'm absolutely
putting her on the spot here so
we could do this later good morning
Lindsey staff commissioner New Hampshire
Department of Revenue Administration
um as I think we've talked about with
this committee we were unable to assign
a number to the impact of single sales
Factor because we were moving the
apportionment
methodology for services and intangibles
from cost of performance to market-based
sourcing and then the impact of single
sales Factor was coming right on the
heels of that and so we didn't have the
data in order to put a specific number
on the impact of single sales factors so
I think just generally From dra's
perspective
there's no tax law change from our
presentations associated with that move
to single sales factor and when we
looked at single sales Factor even under
market-based sourcing or under excuse me
under cost of performance
there are years where single sales
Factor would be a winner and there are
years that it would be a loser it really
just depends some years we would gain
revenue moving to single sales Factor
other years we would lose Revenue moving
to single sales Factor so it is could be
very specific to the year and the
specific businesses and the activity
occurring in that year so we did not we
are unable to describe prescribe any
specific amount to that
follow-up yes but the last uh
of those estimates from before
market-based sourcing that you ran for
us on was after the decision on that I
believe but the month after that
decision but it came in at 70 million
dollars loss in 2016. for that specific
Year and that was a big tax year
and the question now that we're we've
we've got two big tax years
going now right behind us
on it's a little worrying how much it
might end up being
I I would just say I don't think that
the loss of 70 million
in a big tax year I don't think the big
tax year is necessarily driving the loss
it's the type of activities and the
businesses paying those taxes in that
year that determine the impact so you
could also have in theory a big tax year
where the move to single sales Factor
generated revenue and we saw gains in
Revenue if the large business taxpayers
in that year had a significant portion
of sales in New Hampshire
so it really depends on the underlying
yeah just keep in mind let me just
remind everyone that we have another
presentation right after the governor's
office and then uh we have we have
Lindsay for a commissioner
um for the rest of the day basically so
we can keep asking her questions we can
keep going on that one then or I could
just ask this one more question one more
question okay on
we are an elderly Society we consume
less than young societies
and uh we we
on in General on the consumer side we're
not going to get as much as other states
would out of this but on the and on the
manufacturing side the businesses that I
know that do production are
mostly
um
not importing a whole lot of inputs and
selling them
out of New Hampshire so do you but do
you have any
better take on that
I think in terms of consumption as a
society I think it depends on what
you're consuming
so different demographics consume
different types of things
as you age you may consume more Medical
Services or medical devices when you're
younger you may consume we don't collect
the beer tax but you may consume more
beer and pay tax on that so I think
at the end of the day there is a
consumption across Society it's just
what you consume might be different but
at the end of the day single sales
Factor just looks at the sales into the
state and it's all kind of taxed
it's always great to be reunited with my
okay it was on on page four uh again we
have the the the problem the problem of
the real estate transfer attacks and
again are based off of the current
projections uh from January and February
our number is too high and the 227
million that the dra is projecting
um is is controlling
uh just going down the list the Court's
fines and fees they're pretty much
statistically insignificant we have uh
14 million they have 13.9 million
um for a simplicity's sake uh I mean
either number it's not going to matter
but if you want to use theirs so we can
consistently say we use the Department's
estimates the 13.9 would be fine with us
uh the utility property taxes uh they're
coming more and more in line in 2024
we're just 1.7 percent off of the dra uh
revenues we're at 47.1 they're at 46.3
uh I like our number
um I'm just sort of a a nudge to get
those utility values up
um but uh I I think you know a lot of
it's going to be what what transpires
over the next few months but uh April
1st is coming around uh the utility
profits uh their profitability has
skyrocketed uh in the last year and I
think those numbers are going to be
reflected uh with a with a with a better
utility property tax uh although again
our numbers are are getting more and
more in line in in very close and the
last one on the page is recoveries
um
recoveries are always very difficult to
estimate estimate however in the last
three years recoveries have averaged 3.4
million dollars a year
um the the plan was for 2.5 million
they're always they're going to be
between and historically they've always
been between 2 million and 4 million uh
so 2.5 million that we're projecting is
on the lower end their 2 million is on
the very low end again Anything could
happen it's all has to do with what the
courts say but I believe the 200 the 2.5
million dollars that we're projecting is
the right number to use
I'm Adam cheer
yes
um
for 24.
yeah that one we we are we are we are
lower than that
um lower than the uh the dra's estimate
uh again based on on timing and those
revenues we believe the dra number is
correct to the 100.93 yeah we were we
can you go back to something you said
just got me confused uh utility profits
have skyrocketed
can you tell talk to us about that why
uh yeah well without uh that's what it's
it's what I've I've looked at uh reports
for for eversource and some of the other
companies and their profits are up
significantly and uh the utility
property tax is based off of the market
value of what a utility is worth it's
what a what a uh
non-related party would would buy the
utility for if it was at an arms Lake
transaction on the open market
and uh the more profitable a utility is
the higher the value is therefore the
higher the assessed value should be
so increased profitability while maybe
not good for consumers is very good for
utility property tax collection and
representative Doucet just curious in
that explanation does that mean the the
property the real property in relation
to the uh utility
isn't necessarily said it's fluid as to
what their profit line is yes
yeah yeah I mean businesses are assessed
differently than than you would be as a
homeowner your homeowner is like what is
the value what is the market value of
your house whereas a uh and it's based
off of what you could sell the land for
and the improvements for whereas a
business it it's it's sold as an ongoing
concern so there's a revenue stream
attached to it that's projected out and
those uh are taken into account when
assessing for uh for property tax
purposes
how often does that occur every quarter
every fiscal year once a year okay thank
you once a year it's assessed as of
April 1st or the assessments are based
on what the value is on April 1st not
March 30th not April 2nd April 1st and
and they are released uh by December
15th of that following year or that same
year
Madam chair uh representative Platt then
all me and then we'll keep going okay
great thank you
is it's strictly based on a profit index
or is there some net book thrown in
there is a Formula that blends a few
different approaches uh yeah I I know
the dra has a very complicated model
that that brings into account a number
of factors uh which includes uh which
includes the book value Revenue
projection streams as well as the
physical plant that's that's there so
it's a combination of of many different
factors that go into disclosure that's
the industry I came from
okay representative only
thank you um but to the extent that it's
based on profit on they're at a high
right now because they are required to
set the prices once every six months no
matter whether the Market's up or down
and
um The Cooperative New Hampshire
Cooperative actually has considerably
lower prices because they can set them
when the market looks good
and do it whenever they want to
and the new community energy groups are
going to be doing pretty much that same
thing so
and I understand that
the puc and the department of energy are
working hard at this point on whether
they can use a modified version of what
the Cooperative does
as well which would bring down the
prices which would bring down the
profits which by 25 we'd probably see a
decline in that yes uh it's possible but
first they're going to go up
and uh they're not going to get well
they may do that they're not going to
get it done unfortunately before April
1st and that's that's the next time the
revenues are the assessments are going
to be made
uh so which is which is why uh and
you're right that it's not going it
doesn't it hasn't affected all
utility providers equally
uh so which is why we don't have we
don't see Revenue skyrocketing I mean
our our numbers while slightly higher
than the dra in in 24 and they by the
way they come back in line in 25. uh
they do see a little bit of a spike
there because of that and then long term
I think you're you're exactly right
they'll come back down
in in line representative Southworth did
you have a question uh thank you maybe
my own confusion uh we said we were very
optimistic about meals and rentals
am I misreading
um your estimates are much lower than
um the department for both 24 uh for
I don't I thought if you were very
optimistic you'd be closer to the
department asked him yeah uh we are
optimistic uh we want to make it uh
realistic and and Bible so while we're
where we are within their range for
meals and rentals we are at the low end
of the range okay I miss that so that's
there's a little twist there somewhere
yeah so we're within the range it's just
a matter of how much we want to uh and
can you bring it not to belabor it but
um that doesn't really seem to fit with
very optimistic
well I think that the growth rates
though are are are are are are
optimistic oh so you think it's peaking
um yeah I mean it's you think it's going
to flatten they're at an all-time high
and I think that they're going to remain
at an all-time high okay they're not
going to that makes sense thank you all
representative Platt
who does the utility property tax apply
to it's not just polls and wires as it
generators as well it is actually
generators yes okay because uh I was
going to respond to representative Olney
because uh the energy part is just a
pass-through so it doesn't affect
utility profits at all but it does
affect the generators profits if they're
taxed on utility property tax that that
will go up but the utilities themselves
the only reason they might have a higher
profit now because kilowatt hours are up
and they're collecting revenues on a
kilowatt hour basis for a fixed cost so
it gets better with revenues and of
kilowatt hours and we'll go down
kilowatt hours go down is that correct
yes
representative Phyllis
so just so I understand this utility
property tax it's
this one the state revenue is the method
of assessing them in taxing them
completely different from what
municipalities do
no it's not they they they they assessed
or they they should be assessing on on
the same on the same way uh how a
municipality assesses a utility should
be the exact same way a dra uh
assessment when I say exact same way and
generally the same way because there's
more than one way to do it uh but they
should be very similar and they they
should in theory produce similar values
uh and what what we have is is the the
dra assesses utility companies
throughout the state of New Hampshire
for the utility property tax there are
also utility property tax or taxes paid
on the local level
uh and the and those municipalities have
two choices one is they could use the
dra revenues
uh which which the dra provides them
free of free of charge they can just
give them to them or they can uh hire
their their own uh Municipal assessing
expert to assess the utilities uh or or
contract with a private company to do so
but but it it it is the for the local
property tax uh they are assessed Maybe
by a different company which most of
them are than the dra the dra is
strictly for the Statewide utility
property tax why don't we this is kind
of drilling down to an expertise that
the dra would have
um so why don't we keep moving because
we want to hear what the governor's
logic was in all of these numbers and
then we can go back to that okay thank
you
right
uh now turning to I'm actually now
and you see here that there are no new
items that stand out
and that the uh that are upt number the
utility property tax number is is now in
back in line with the dra estimates
because they they believe that you know
the the numbers going up as do we uh and
in total our revenues are 4.5 percent
lower than those provided by the
Departments with the caveat again has
been pointed out we did take for for
some of these at least the high end of
the dra range although that that
thank you
sorry
yes sir are you thinking um the real
estate property tax again will be closer
to the department absolutely okay yeah
that take take the dras we we uh we're
relying on December numbers and uh you
know given what's happened in January
and February belonging the December
numbers was a mistake and the dra's
latest numbers are the ones that we
believe are correct that would extend to
2024 and 25 as well that all those
numbers will be put in hours eventually
that have been changed
for our sheets
I mean he's reading us the new numbers
for those are eventually going to go in
so no the the official Governor's
numbers are the ones that are in your
sheet the numbers that were contained in
the summary okay so what since that
point in time
the director Gary is letting you know
that if they had done revenues today
they would have okay probably done
something differently but the governor's
official numbers are the governor's
officials okay and we can just know it
for our information right thank you
yeah it's true the the numbers are the
numbers but I want to make sure that you
know where we stand so you can get your
numbers so I'll you know with the same
now on page six uh page six and seven
just to end we have the highway uh the
highway fund and and Fish and Game fund
on the next page as a highway fund it
closely mirrors uh
our number is closely mirror that
provided by safety uh for fiscal year 23
our revenues are 1.66 percent lower than
theirs again this small discrepancy is
really a timing issue
uh unlike the real estate transfer tax
the latest numbers from the highway plan
were a positive uh 2.7 percent over plan
uh and and that was actually in January
so therefore for fiscal year 23 I
believe the Department's estimate of
257.7 million is actually the correct
number so we'll be actually increasing
uh
our number for that
uh in fiscal year 24 and 25 our numbers
total those provided by safety but
because we we based our increase off of
23 uh a couple of the numbers uh are a
little bit different the gas total and
the motor vehicle fees are a little bit
different again uh just 0.16 and 0.15
off it's it's almost a rounding error
but uh you know the the bottom line
number of 258.8 million in 24 and 259.3
million and 25 are you know are are
together
uh and really the same thing for fish
and game uh in 23 are estimate of 13.3
million for the fish and game fund is
slightly under the Department's
prediction of 13.76 million but then
going forward uh the numbers are fairly
consistent and steady uh no major growth
or decline we are predicted projecting
13.37 million for both 24 and 25 which
is the Department of Fish and games
representative all me thank you and I
was trying to find the place in the
governor's executive budget summary uh
in order to be able to compare last
night and the only thing that I found
was page 17.
general fund and total funds expenditure
summary
and
oh no sorry 16. the budget summary
source of funds on the highway fund
there
for 20
23 which is what I'm looking at right
2 and in oh and adjusted adjusted
authorized is 265 but the
these numbers seem to be a little bit
different from okay I don't I don't have
a copy of that in front of me actually
this is the capital budget I wasn't sure
if it was equivalent to what we were
looking at before which is comparing
page 15 the unrestricted Revenue with
what we had before okay as as soon as
absolutely
okay uh for the revenue figures uh and
the governor's executive budget summary
yeah it depends on which revenues you
you count and not there are a lot of
different moving Parts here uh but I I
okay
yeah I can I can get you
um at first I assure you that our
numbers are equal to them and what
happens is and and
um it was just whispered in my ear which
is actually correct is the uh the cost
of collections is different and so
that's why these numbers are a little
bit different than the actual Revenue
projections
okay
uh and again just finished up with the
fish and game fund uh as I mentioned
again our numbers are are uh the same
for fiscal year 24 and 25 slightly
different in fiscal year 23 but again
it's it's roughly 400 000 we are less
so
and with that I'll if there are any
remaining questions excellent
presentation and and I think we'll be
quoting you in your introductory remarks
when we get to the floor any other
questions
thank you very much it was a pleasure
and please reach out if you have any
additional questions uh over the next
few days as you're doing your tough job
of deciding what numbers to go with
right we have a little bit more
information now we've been doing this a
few more weeks after you finish so yes
thank you thank you very much
okay uh Chris do you want to come up or
do we have Lottery Commission here
do we have handouts coming our way we do
wonderful
understanding
thank you
okay welcome back
thank you for working during vacation
week of course uh just gets away from my
kids thank you uh Madam chair members of
the committee uh my name is Charlie
McIntyre privilege of being director of
Hampshire lottery
um
I uh put together we sort of generated
some breakdowns of how our revenues are
generated
by product line
and I'll go through them very quickly
obviously I don't want to re recite what
you can read easily um but certainly
I'll go by product type
uh insta tickets obviously or scratch
tickets which you probably are familiar
with
um the margin on these products varies
wildly by Price Point as you can imagine
a dollar ticket has lower price
structure than a 25 ticket does
so the Blended
margin is about 18 on those give or take
and last year our sales were 313 million
dollars on that product line
multi-state jackpot games uh most
well-known are Powerball and Mega
Millions they're sold throughout the
nation
um the margin is incredibly high on
those at 39 percent approximately
last year we did 59 million this year
we've already exceeded that number
to date and we still have obviously a
number of months to go
this year's revenue on Powerball Mega
Millions is anomalously high
because of interest rates
so what happens with Powerball and Mega
Millions is we sell a ticket and then
say it's a dollar of that dollar 33
sense of it essentially goes into a
jackpot fund that jackpot fund is then
multiplied by a bond Factor that gets us
our jackpot
so three years ago the bond Factor was
approximately 1.4 the bond Factor now is
approximately 2.4 so you that's one of
the reasons you've seen several several
I think it's three billion dollar
jackpots and one two billion dollar
jackpot is because interest rates have
increased the
jackpot size and increase the marketing
opportunities and
that certainly we anticipate to not be
the norm going forward
moreover there's a function in our
business called jackpot fatigue
you know a billion dollars isn't what it
um as the job when you see it over and
over again it loses the interest the
news isn't is interested media is not as
interested so
it it declines it just does
the next grouping is called Tri-State
games these are a number of tickets that
we sell collectively with Vermont and
Maine based on a compact dating back to
1986 signed by then governor sununu
um
the tickets vary by product line the
overall
margin is approximately 20 and last year
we sold about 39 million dollars of that
those games tend to be pretty stable
um and therefore it make estimating easy
for Powerball Mega Millions are
fluctuate wildly I mean by tens of
millions of dollars annually so it makes
estimating very hard candidly
um the next product is called Lucky for
Life it's a ticket that we started
with the New England states and now it's
about 22 States across the country do it
toward 25.
um it has a set jackpot prize you win a
thousand dollars a day for Life
obviously it's a very good price
um we do about eight million dollars
last year in that and that's stable as
well
Keno is a game that this body approved
in 2017
uh it was initially limited to bars and
taverns it is now authorized within
convenience stores in cities and towns
that have approved Keno
um our margin on that is about 19
percent
sales with 53 million dollars last year
um so it's not quite 10 million
profitability
the next category is called ilottery
which is you can use your phone or your
computer to buy lottery tickets
uh Powerball Mega Millions as well as
what we call e-instance which are
scratch tickets through your phone
um we don't recognize
gross revenues in that context we only
recognize what we call Gross Gaming
revenue which is money after prizes
because what happens is you can use you
can play for very low dollar amounts you
can play a instant scratch ticket for
three cents and if you win you know if
better nickel win a nickel there's a
constant flow so we only recognize it as
sort of money that's left at the end of
the day
um
for revenue and that would be just about
30 million dollars last year
and then obviously a very topical
product is sports betting
um
which we launched in December 30th 2019
once again sales are recognized in Gross
Gaming revenue we don't recognize the we
recognize it but we don't really
consider the amount bet because it's
such a large number it's more akin to
like stock trading because you know I
bet you bet 100 that 100 goes back and
forth a bunch of times so it's uh
Revenue last year was approximately 23
on the next page is a pie chart
which is a breakdown of our expenses
and as you can see this is for
traditional Lottery
the largest expense we have is prizes UH
60 cents of the dollar essentially goes
back to prizes the second largest is the
distribution of the education trust fund
which is set
27.3 percent
the next largest is the retailer
commission at 5.7
vendor fees of 3.6 percent
administrative costs of 1.6 percent
Instant tickets and delivery is 1.3
so as you could you know we're obviously
proud of the fact that we're remarkably
lean
uh on the next page Begins the breakdown
of charitable gambling
in this in the New Hampshire
we regulate uh four different types of
charitable gambling
Bingo Lucky Seven games of chance and
historic horse racing there is a fifth
category of charitable gambling in the
broadest sense that would be raffles we
have no role in Raffles we often get
that question but Raffles are governed
by uh jurisdictional law enforcement so
police departments for cities and towns
um and I don't know how much you want to
go through this there's a very distinct
breakdown of all the various charitable
gambling and the
Revenue received by the state as well as
the charities in the next two pages
um
and then the last page is a breakdown
also a pie chart for games of chance in
historic horse racing for calendar year
22.
you have a further handout a single page
which is the revenue streams involved
uh and our projected
basis for our Revenue estimates I think
we provide those Revenue estimates to
you
a number of days ago
um but here is a breakdown of how we
arrive at those Revenue estimates
both on the lottery Division and well it
says investigative and compliance
division that's charitable gambling
charitable gambling is governed by that
division within our agency
um
so sorry
single Peak yep
um is a breakdown of those most notably
I'll sort of get ahead of the questions
on draw based games we anticipate a drop
off
significantly significantly based on the
Powerball Mega Millions situation which
I explained
further sports betting we would
anticipate a
an effect of Massachusetts
launching sports betting and
that we derive a significant portion of
our player base from Massachusetts and
those are really the two areas we
anticipate an effect
I would note that a revenue estimated
170 million 0.8 for FY 23
is almost double what we had transferred
at FY 18. so we've undergrown tremendous
growth and so mixed Revenue estimates
kind of tricky
and with that I'll answer any questions
you may have
about anything
representative elberger has a question
thank you madam chair I'm just uh
looking at the single sheet
the games of chance and there's a
significant drop in this year and I
assume that's based on the that just
what you were talking about it is and
also the the conversion to Historic
horse racing some of the rooms had
closed
um and at weren't open for a period of
time so there was a drop-off thank you
representative yes thank you madam chair
I'm just looking at this sheet as well
on the sports betting
the projections look well they're looked
down on 224 which you I think you
addressed that but largely flat
and
you know I think I I guess I want a
little more information on that it
appears to me as a consumer that this
sports betting is blowing up I mean
DraftKings bar stool I mean it seems
like it's getting pop more popular all
around the country
um so wonder why we're projecting a kind
of a flat trajectory so um
I the flight trajectory is taking into
account both the growth as well as the
negative impact of Massachusetts
so while we if Mass didn't exist we
would be I don't say hockey stick growth
because we're number two in the nation
per capita for sports betting revenue
for the state out of the 30 somewhat
States we're number two so
um you know that's pretty good
um and so it's taking representative
your question that's taking into account
both continued growth as well as a
negative impact for Mass
thank you
and Kennedy we tend to be try to be on
the conservative side of real estate to
our numbers because we understand that
you folks spend it before we can make it
so
I'm just this is this is not the
spending committee
representative or says a question
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my question you may have already said
but on the single sheet under racing in
historic horse racing that's quite a
climb so did I miss something or did I
no you folks that approved historic
horse racing during the last legislative
session it's taking them a while to get
up and running online and that's what we
anticipate the growth to look like it'll
be it's almost new Revenue like I
hesitate to even put an FY
um 22 numbers because they almost didn't
exist and so
um they're taking a while to get going
so that's why thank you very much
the last uh page before the the numbers
page on are those are the is the
historic horse racing
but it's going to look very different
for this year yes very much so much has
come in so far
um because they were all
building and things like that too and
they still are I get to the the updated
number still there's going to be a
casino just down the road from me and
they're calling it slots okay I don't
but
and we still have a Prohibition against
slots
representative Malloy
thank you madam chair for taking my
question uh
the
I'm looking at the last page of your
your work the pie charts
a historic horse racing
and
how
I'm I'm not making a connection between
your sheet your one sheet that says
historic horse racing and those numbers
and this number on historic horse racing
of
a lot of money
uh
is there is there a connection here or
not or there is good if I could explain
uh apologize there's a bit of confusion
and it's our fault
um the number on the single sheet are
fiscal year 22 so they end as of June
30th of 22. the numbers in the pie chart
are more updated so they're calendar
year 22 and a number of the facilities
opened uh in the latter half of count
year 22 which would be reflected in
follow up
so
even in 23
historic horse racing you show
seven
so is that the
is that the Rev well I guess what I'm
asking is that that's is that this what
you're looking at is the state and
charity Revenue in that is that is that
the number that's reflected no that's
the state revenue charity revenue is
separate yeah state
I I may need to take this offline I'm
not report that following you know these
okay sorry um Mr Shea suggested I break
down so the one sheet which is a revenue
streams is a gross number
just wanted to make sure that was clear
that you didn't spend this
um and
um our Revenue estimates we had
submitted before our
um 170 for FY 23 158 for FY 24 and 163
representative Ames
so on the on that on the
estimates of Revenue that go into the
general or education fund because they
go into the education trust fund
um
my question is uh
regarding level of confidence in these
numbers
um or if you did a dra's way
which is a range they give us a range a
high and a low
um would we see a substantial spread
well certainly in the sense of there's a
number of products we sell that
fluctuate pretty broadly and so I would
say these aren't conservative but
they're the second cousin of
conservatives
there are the the lower end of realistic
and not high certainly
um
is there anything different this time
around for this next to this projection
compared with you know previous times or
is this just sort of the same situation
that you've always struggled with
um it's less a struggle now than it used
to be only because when I first took
this job we depended so much on
Powerball
and Mega Millions that it fluctuated
wildly if you looked at our Revenue
sheets you would see it look like the
Alps and you know up down up down up
down it was like Magic Mountain
um and now it's because so much of what
we sell is more stable that it's far
easier easy it's not easy it's more
agreeable to give Revenue estimates so
we're more confident certainly I am I'm
Jim than we were then it would have been
10 years ago
one of those questions yeah follow-up
um this is a little bit different but on
on this uh this page that you gave us
today
um
which is gross or close to gross
revenues this is the gross revenues yeah
those revenues
um
do you have have this kind of breakdown
for the uh not the go the the trans that
becomes the transfer we do we do and
it's
um it's I'm hesitant to send it out only
because like for us if I send you Mega
Millions estimate
it will fluctuate wildly in Powerball
will fluctuate wildly so I'm hesitant to
send you the the margin is the margin
and so when they're all Blended together
it's more agreeable but we do yeah
okay representative
is there a limit to how Deep Pockets are
and uh
uh the plethora of games here are they
interfering with each other eating into
each other some so that's an excellent
question representative uh it's one we
think about and study all day every day
um
the short answer is I don't know what
the
limit is
I just know we haven't hit it yet
for example like sports betting was
entirely new Revenue that I don't think
cannibalized a dollar from anybody like
appropriated or repatriated funds that
were in the legal Market or going
offline or offshore to bid on Sports
like I think sports betting existed in
this day before we legalized it we just
appropriated it so it's a good question
and we studied every day because
cannibalization is a big part of our
representative Army has a question thank
you I just wanted to make sure I
understood some of these things on on
page well 43 of the annual comprehensive
Financial reports so presumably if I
went online I could find it absolutely
the annual Port is um online and
presented to fiscal and it's on our
website but I thought I put down
everything correctly and as you were
saying it and uh Instant tickets and
delivery whatever delivery is on
was that the 1.3 it is yes
we've got all these memorized and on
that the last page of that uh is this
net or gross
the net the net is what is labeled as
state yes it is yes I mean we haven't
deducted expenses from this but yes like
our salaries and the like but it's net
to the state it's not the net transfer
net including Administration costs
I'm sorry
um by our CFO suggests we don't offset
expenses on stroke horse racing we have
a minute we have administrative expenses
but that's reported it's net revenue on
the upper side of the income statement
as well so there's no cost of sales
coming below that okay so other than the
very small percentage of administrative
expenses it's
it's basically the net I know I know you
have very low administrative expenses I
started out back in the United States in
Gainesville Florida when they were
discovering that they were costing 10
okay thank you very much sorry for the
delay
okay
uh Madam chair
so I have questions when you're ready
yes so uh representative Southwest has
some uh General comments and questions
he'd like to ask go ahead
we had emailed back and forth already
um I just want to follow up a little
more on where all of the 10 raises were
some people have asked me about that in
my community and the first part is so
that's for anyone who is a state
employee from Administration all the way
down to any Department
is that
so the the raises are going to be
included in House Bill 2. you'll see an
appropriation in the house bill too
along with some language changes that
would adjust salaries for the justices
um The Lottery Commission uh commission
members as well as for the legislative
branch it's uh there's a language
there's money in the in the house bill
too but there's language that says that
the um authorities within the
legislative branch would need to approve
the raise and do they already know how
much the total is give or take yeah it's
it's the in the appropriation that's
contained in House Bill too and I don't
have it right in front of me but I can
get that at lunch because people just
have been asking about it I want to be
clear I think that's a great question
and by now we normally have House Bill
too it seems like it's been two weeks do
we know where that is
um it's still being drafted and it's on
track for coming out around the same
time as it did last budget cycle so it's
it's a fairly huge document and it's got
over 200 pages that came from the
governor so the uh
drafting office office of legislative
Services is going through that document
and it's not as simple as a cut and
paste into a bill but they actually have
to go in and
um one check statutes against what's
being suggested in the governor's
um bill so if if it's the repeal of the
CST
the governor may put repeal CST but they
have to go into our statutes and make
sure that anything that CST might be
referenced in is also repealed so it
takes a little bit of time in fact
they've divided it up among the
attorneys within that office and if
anybody's been into the department or
into the office lately you may
understand that they're down to
attorneys right now so they've got six
attorneys that are working on this
um
three of them are essentially brand new
this session
and um and then three what I would say
veteran attorneys so it's taken some
time to get it but I don't think it's
out of whack yet
representative South with you had more
questions than I interrupted go ahead no
that was on target so we can expect that
to be a large number basically but it's
going to be then a large at first and
then spread out among all the
Departments and so on right so the
appropriation is by source of funds yeah
and I can I can give you a ballpark I
just don't have the exact number but the
total amount is about 100 million each
year
but that comes from all fun sources
that'd be general fund right that would
be sweepstakes or Lottery Commission
that would be other funds that would be
federal funds that's that's very helpful
and then for us some of the people who
are relatively new
um could you say a little more about
um the Surplus statement and the fact
that it isn't necessarily a surplus
right so in the governor's executive
budget you'll see in there he has a
one moment
so it's on page 15.
so on 14 is um
the statement as it 20 through 20
through 2022 and then on 15 you'll see
excuse me that's the revenues
back up one page 13 is the governor's 23
through 24 25 Surplus
part of what the governor has done in
House Bill 2 is appropriated
um about
550 million dollars
of 23 revenue or 23 funds 24 funds and
25 funds
and what that does is it gets you down
to the amount going into the rainy day
fund at the end of the biennium
so at the end of 23 they're projecting
to increase from 159 to 253 and then by
the end of 25 the end of the biennium it
would be up to 341 in the rainy day fund
so in addition to the house bill 2
Revenue excuse me Appropriations that
the governor is making there's another
close to 400 million dollars in
legislative specials that have
Appropriations
so at this point there's really not a
surplus until decisions are made on
those bills that have Appropriations
attached to them and until the budget is
determined and then as part of our
office we would update the Surplus for
the house so based on decisions that the
house makes in terms of legislative
specials you may pass or decisions you
make in the operating budget and with
your revenues we would update that to
reflect your your decision and show it
against the governor's projections and
then the Senate would do the same thing
the Senate would come through and and do
estimates for its revenues would do a
budget and make priorities as it seems
to need as well as a pro Appropriations
and legislative specials that they might
pass
so we won't truly know how much of a
surplus there is until you get done
making all those decisions because you
may spend a lot of that money
um through House Bill 2 or other uh
legislative specials that's helpful and
then for our committee if we do make
changes that pass basically those would
go into the Surplus statement as well
that's correct so other you're going to
come out of this committee with your
unrestricted revenues for the general
fund the highway fund and the Fish and
Game fund
from that well my office will do an
amendment to House Bill one to reflect
this committee's decisions on the
unrestricted revenues any other
decisions that are made as it relates to
revenues for instance if you were to
agree with the governor's repeal of the
CST as the house body and you pass
legislation to do that we would reflect
that by removing it on the Surplus
statement there'd be a line below the
what we call schedule two that would
make an adjustment to revenue to reflect
the the change in the CST if you added
um you know you decided to go back up to
nine percent on the community on the
meals and rooms tax through a
legislative special and that passed the
body that potential increase in Revenue
again would be carried on what we call
schedule two of the Surplus statement to
adjust the revenues at the end so that
at the end of the process the
legislative body knows that it will have
a balanced budget so at the end of
fiscal year 25 that your budget would be
balanced thank you madam chair for
indulging me
absolutely those are good observations
and questions representative Almy and
then representative Platt
on
could you
explain to us what it takes to get money
out of the rainy day fund in times of
emergency
and on and I think we must have done it
in
in on 08 no9
if there was any left by 0-9 so how did
we do that because I don't think we
could use what's in the
in the legislation yeah so by Statute if
your revenues
are less than what you anticipated in
your expense or and or your expenditures
are more than you anticipated and you
don't have enough money
to meet your obligations by law at the
end of the biennium money would be the
transferred would be transferred out of
the rainy day fund
um and and that did happen back in
11 I think it was
well it was maybe it was on nine there
was 89 million dollars taken out of the
rainy day fund and used it for operating
expenses
that all being said
if law is suspended
you can take money out of the rainy day
fund as you did last year with the
settlement money as it relates to the
YDC
so you took 100 million the legislature
took 100 million dollars out of the
rainy day fund and you've locked that up
to be used towards the potential
settlements that might be come to as it
follow up and then represent
yes I think I I was told but not very
often that it takes on if we used the uh
short of Revenue section uh it we would
have to be 20 percent under our
estimated revenues
oh I'd have to check to see if there's a
threshold but I don't recall off the top
statement which will lead to a question
I'm not a sanguine at all as uh Mr Jerry
is that we're going to avoid a recession
and I I see the uh feds keep racking up
raising the interest rates I see Wall
Street Journal vignettes they're all
fact but I add together
uh and I won't get into the detail and
it's only my opinion but that led to a
question I asked through you to dra
which is what is the real estate Revenue
real estate transfer tax revenue been in
previous recession years adjusted for
today's housing prices to see if we had
some sort of data we could apply here if
there were a recession
so good news at one o'clock when dra
comes back in they'll be providing you
some information related to that
question
representative Doucette has a question
or statement real quick is there a a cap
specific to the rainy day fund and what
is that cap so there's a cap at the end
of the biennium you can't exceed 10 of
your general fund Revenue so right now
it's about 400 million dollars
approximately
representative
okay it representative fellows
um thank you I'm wondering uh Chris if
you can just help me understand page 13
so so it's down under the legislative
editions it says
sb2
2023 session and it and it already has
deductions there but we didn't we
haven't passed any bills I mean you know
we had no bills have been enacted I
don't understand what that represents
so in House Bill 2 the legislature has
at times appropriated funds from the
current by uh fiscal year that you're in
and you've made it non-lapsing through
the biennium you've done this in 21 and
19 I think as far back as 17 and off the
top of my head where there was excess
Revenue that the legislature
appropriated for a purpose and and move
that forward through the next biennium
so that is what you see with that line
House Bill too that's the governor's
Appropriations in House Bill 2 for
fiscal year 23 would equal about 224.5
million dollars of General funds of
which part of that
um excuse me and then you you look over
to 24 you have 89 million and 12.5 for a
total of 105 and then
57.75 for a total of 132 and 25. so
these are all Appropriations that will
be contained in house bill 2. for the
24-25 number that you see for the
general fund that a piece of that will
the other thing is if you look at 23
you're going to see just above that line
it says law is a 2022 additional
Appropriations so last year the
legislature appropriated funds for
fiscal year 22 because of the um how
well revenues were doing in an effort to
spend some of that money in in areas
that the legislature felt would be
important some of those Appropriations
didn't
um get used because of the timing
so they're going to be booked in the
accounting this year
so that's what the 279 million dollars
that that's from
Appropriations made in 22 that were
representative
thank you madam chair I want to go back
to the salary increases for a moment
is the percentage increase in aggregate
for all jobs or is it a flat percentage
for every
employee
so the union negotiated with the
executive team a 10 pay raise for
everybody so it's each each person will
get 10 of their salary
thank you thank you two percent in the
second year
um so that's what the union negotiated
the what we call unrepresented that's
what um some of the language in House
Bill 2 addresses so there are people who
aren't part of the Union
that um the decision has been made to
give them what the unions negotiated so
it would be some agencies have members
that aren't part of the Union you have a
administrative staff that aren't part of
the union and then you have employees in
the legislative branch and in the
judicial branch that aren't part of a
union that would be eligible for the pay
raise and that's what that's addressing
and this and that would be on top of the
regular step increases they're already
getting if they're getting one yeah it's
admin Services would have the number
better than I but for a period of time
many positions had been filled for such
a long time by the same person that
individuals were at Max or close to at
representative
do you have uh an idea of how what the
inflation has been since the last time
there was a salary increase
like this
or something like this so I for the
Union
I I don't have anything official I mean
in our office we were looking around and
it appears that
um potentially this this increase that's
being proposed would um kind of take
care of aligning the salaries with
inflation over a period of time
but I don't have any specific figures
yes and and the other question is oh is
there any place in the budget area where
he's taking care of the fact that on
the nursing homes are
on our that are County run
are having to increase their salaries
and the um the Meals on Wheels people
and senior centers and such are having
to increase their salaries
so the county cap issue is addressed in
um
in the House Bill 2 was part of the
operating budget as well
um
that's adjusted each biennium
I can't say it's addressing all of what
your concerns might be but there's an
increase in the number of that cap in
terms of rates for programs such as
meals and Meals on Wheels and and
providers that might provide home health
or home care that's negotiated through
rates through the operating budget of
Health and Human Services so as Finance
works on the operating budget for Health
and Human Services there may be some
adjustments I don't know what was
included in the base numbers that the
governor has in terms of helping out
some of those entities but something we
could probably get you
one other just quick comment I know that
Finance because they have a number of
questions around the pay raise is trying
to schedule a meeting with
administrative services
to come in and talk about how the pay
raise works and what would impact and
probably address a lot of the questions
that members here are having so if I
find that date I will email it to you
and let you know when they're going to
okay folks we have 15 minutes before the
lunch break we could continue and maybe
look at an easier Revenue item to
discuss and take a straw vote on or we
could break now come back at one and and
start then what's the pleasure of the
committee members
thank you
guys have another 15 minutes in you to
do some stuff
okay
Chris you had mentioned a couple of
eight uh agency numbers we could look at
so last time we met you were
um considering looking at the other and
then I asked you to pause on that
because I was concerned about why my
number was so out of whack I've sent you
a couple of emails to explain that I
asked a question of the treasurer and um
the Comptroller
and my communication probably wasn't as
clear as it should have been they
thought I was talking about 24 25 when I
asked the question they agreed with me
um I in my head I was including 23 when
in fact they weren't so
um the number that for 23 is the 97
million dollars and I've explained to
the agency's recommended number of 79
76 million
which included 13
um included 17 million of the interest
that was being discussed so if you
recall the treasurer had presented that
there was 35 million dollars of
potential Revenue interest in 23 17 of
that was already in that number of 76.
so 18 million should have been added to
76. the other thing that wasn't included
was a three million dollar lawsuit so
that's not typically budget but there
would excuse me settlement not lawsuit
there was three million dollars that
came in in 2023 related to a uh
settlement so that would be included in
so just to confirm what you're talking
about as we're looking at our major big
worksheet we're looking under column l
general fund right yep which is
Department administrative Services quote
unquote other
and what we've heard from the governor
and from Chris is that the number for
Line 13 house Ways and Means should
potentially be 97. if we agree
if you agree uh right okay
number was 97 so it would be up to you
to decide if you agree with that or not
okay all right yes please representative
where did the 76 come from all of a
sudden
so when administrative Services came
before you in their document they had a
number 76. so that didn't include
18 million dollars of Interest or the
legal settlement
so they were just showing you that you
know for 23 if you were comparing all
the revenues that they typically track I
okay so uh Chris was thinking that
because now we've figured out what was
the difference because that was our
question there why was there a
difference in the numbers and now we
figured it out it was just a kind of
tabulation error
okay
and then uh
it goes up and down slightly from there
in 2024 and 2025 on your worksheet
and that up and down is mainly driven by
if you look at the interest Revenue it
goes up and then it's 35 31 and then
down to 24.
are you looking for uh this might be a
nice time to make a motion for straw
vote
or other
97 million for FY 23 99 million for 24
and
94.6 for
. is there a second representative what
any more questions
all those in favor oh there's a question
representative Phyllis yeah so
I understand
the the change for the um 2023
I'm don't understand why 24 would be
higher when you look back at
and to that you add 31 million in
interest they anticipate
or
which year
for 24.
is that the number that's the number
you're talking about
okay so it's because interest rates are
a lot higher than they have been uh the
the reason that there's so much interest
revenue is that the state is uh flush
with cash right now and the treasurer is
investing that to get a return so that
interest is coming to the state as well
with also a higher rate than there than
there was two or three years ago partly
yes yeah okay I'm good
okay any more discussion all those in
favor of that motion you want to raise
okay it looks like unanimous I don't
know what the number is count the number
for me I think it's 16 is that it
okay so stravo looks like we've got that
I'm Adam chair defending
representative Southworth um can we do
Lottery since we just heard from them
15. okay so we have 15 people here today
and so uh we could I well sure we could
try talking about Lottery what do we
think
wanna what are the odds
Madam chair representative I have no
reason to dispute
uh the agency with respect to these
numbers so I would move a straw number
for 23 of 170.8
uh 158 for 24 and 163 for 25.
is there a second
okay I'm representative Rose Schertz
all right anyone have some discussion on
that
representative fellows I I would just
agree with the motion because there are
so many different pieces to the lottery
and so many
um
variables that are going to affect it
going forward I think that the Lottery
Commission is just the the is you know
can come up with any better estimate
anyone else okay uh nope no other hands
all those in favor of the motion please
raise your hand
looks like everyone thank you okay so
15-0
it's nice to get the easier stuff done
uh anything else you'd like to bring to
I mean I don't there's liquor if anybody
would like to maybe approach liquor I
think you were waiting on the governor
to explain the governor's office to
explain why in 23 they they had 135 and
that um
um liquor had 130 in
but if it's more discussion maybe you
want to go to lunch and come back after
and do some of this
okay I just heard representative fellows
you're thinking that we wait till after
lunch and kind of mull that one over
okay
uh could we just do um cue the Medicaid
recoveries
phew
I think we did that yeah so and in the
document
hopefully you have shades
it would show that that's where you
tentatively had some agreements um the
other day yeah but
if you need to revisit it that's as well
representative putt we do oh utility
property tax
I want to hold off on that one I have
lots more thinking to do I thought I
understood that one and now I've got to
rethink it a little bit
if you don't mind
G Communications tax we have to show a
right because we we have to assume that
the current law right correct right so
uh
we have an agency low estimate of 28.8
agency High estimate of 29.9 not too far
off for 2023
then the range when I look at the the
details goes from 27.9 to 29.9 roughly
my own calculations so and I moved the
governor's estimate 28.9 for all three
years
so you don't think it will go down in
the next two years I'm guess I'm going
to throw that out there
maybe but it's it's going down to the
infinite slow rate now
so it it I don't think the change if we
reflected would amount anything in the
representative all mean then
um I think for the small numbers when
they're when they are
going down then they are very likely to
continue going down if it's not repealed
on then it's better to reflect them and
I
I think I'm I've been trying to find it
but I think that last year we came in at
28.9 or something like that so we
shouldn't
go below go above the
the numbers that they
okay other comments on CST okay so the
motion is to use
28.9 for all three years just want to
make sure I got that right
any other comments
representative fellows
Governor's estimate is in between the
okay
any other comments okay all those in
favor for the Straub whole vote raise
your hand of that motion
okay looks unanimous
nope no I apologize so 14 to 1.
is that correct okay great
all right again we can go back and visit
these if we really need to
representative orrs
thank you madam chair I I think uh
representative Albany has a good point
just for the record
absolutely
every Point here is good
except for mine
okay all right let's stop now
and come back at one and oh
representative is there something over
we have a presentation tomorrow uh there
was a request for more detail on the
insurance and we do have a meeting at 11
tomorrow on that and more information
forthcoming we can certainly
take that up today if we want but we
might want to wait to get that Intel
representative Olney
was my request because in the past they
have given us information on what parts
of the insurance
were on soft markets meaning that they
couldn't charge as much for the
insurance as they had done versus hard
markets which was that they could charge
the Earth
and on I I didn't we do have a new
insurance department
this is the first time there hasn't been
the woman that was always doing the
calculations and I just wanted to be
reassured that they are doing those
yes and that's why we've requested them
to come back based on your requests find
out what they actually got
at the end of March
just in brief Norma retired that's why
you didn't see her again Amy duhame has
taken over her position
um but Amy and and uh uh DJ Bettencourt
will be here tomorrow to talk to you and
try to address your questions or any
other that the committee might have as
it relates to the revenue uh collected
by the department would it be possible
if they have their presentation already
done and they could email it to us today
that way we could look at it and be more
prepared for tomorrow is that any chance
um if I get it yep and I'll reach out to
him again that's what I've been trying
to do with all these presentations
um but it's not working out that way
well we understand how busy they are but
that helps us kind of think about things
a little bit more prepared with
questions understood yeah okay okay
great we'll see you back here at one
o'clock
sorry I'm late let's go ahead and get
started again this is our time to
talk about start talking about some of
the tougher categories and seeing if we
can get to consensus on any of them
we have folks from the dra thank you
back with us to help us oh they're
spread out
um
and a reminder that tomorrow we have a
presentation from the insurance
department as well as Employment
Security on the employment world
so
yes
so do we write up a report when we the
the bill there's a bill that's going to
be the budget does it have a bill number
so the budget is composed of houses I'm
sorry our Revenue estimates no we will
do what's called a resolution well it's
a house resolution it is I guess it is
it's a resolution which will become an
amendment or part of the house does it
get a report that goes with it the same
way a bill does
Chris do you want to talk to this a
so typically the resolution is
introduced on the day of a session and
members from the Ways and Means
Committee will present that resolution
to the full body
um what's happened the last few times is
there's a vote taken the bodies accepted
the revenues and then they are tabled so
that resolution gets tabled
Because the actual unrestricted revenues
will be included in house bill one
so that that bill will carry the
revenues across basically what the Ways
and Means Committee is doing with its
resolution is letting the rest of the
body know you've come to do a decision
on what you believe the revenue should
be in house bill one
in general let me just so we would we
would write our own committee blurb so I
would write that open to edits and input
obviously
I'm gonna say it's just what the
resolution just to clarify it's just
numbers it's a chart with numbers in it
it's not it's not language at least
unless there's some qualifier in there
that's exactly right it's basically
there's I think four or five lines that
lead into the actual numbers basically
saying this is to restate the 23 24 25
unrestricted revenues
um you'll have a column that is the
planned revenues for 23 and then there
will be what the committee believes the
23 Revenue estimates should be as well
as 24 and 25. if you recall on the day
that I presented to you in the LBA
document if you look at that there's
house resolution 11 that's the
resolution that was submitted
um the last budget cycle and that gives
you the framework that would be used for
your resolution that you would come up
for this session based on your decisions
here the next couple of days
representative Army
yes and what would be the blurb is the
statement uh spoken or read on the floor
by the chair usually which
um
which explains things that they think
people would might want to ask questions
about and then people may ask questions
after that about something that wasn't
covered or they didn't understand and
that has never been motioned into the
official record
so we have no records of what
uh and nor major and other people said
yeah and that's that's fine again
because we know what we're doing is
estimates we're and it's we're doing it
at a point of time with the best
information that we have and we may go
back and do it again
we might be asked to do it again because
in April the world may be changed for
all we know was there any other hand
over here
okay uh
do we want to start looking at another
Revenue item
if I might I would encourage you to have
dra come up and look at maybe those
revenues that they deal with so that if
there's questions that you have you can
ask them that and once you're done with
dra today then maybe we could look at
the highway fund revenues
because I think uh director Gary
answered some questions related to that
but other than that I I would really
foreign
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee Lindsey stepp commissioner
New Hampshire Department of Revenue
happy to answer any questions I will
note you have in front of you copies of
three emails that have been sent out
over the past few weeks one of which was
this morning so you may not have seen it
yet
um but you all have that in your email
but we wanted to provide hard copies as
well those are answers to I think at
this point most if not all of the
questions that we have received up into
this point
so just wanted to be thorough and make
sure everyone had a copy of those we're
happy to answer any questions related to
those as well representative Platt I'd
just like to say thank you for the work
you did on real estate transfer tax
during previous recessionary years
adjusted for today's prices it gives me
some idea what we might expect going
into what I believe to be a recession
sure you're very welcome that was Lauren
and Keen that did that work what
representative plett's referring to is
in your packet he had asked for kind of
a history of real estate transfer tax
during recessions so what we did is we
took the history of the real estate
transfer tax we essentially normalized
it to today's rate because there's been
numerous rate changes over the history
of the tax so it's essentially using the
current rate and then we adjusted the
revenue based based on the change in the
median home sales price over the time
period as well so we've essentially
brought historic Rhett to the current
rate and to today's home price and then
highlighted for you where recessions
have occurred and the reason or the
cause if we had one for the recession so
again giving you kind of a history of
what happens to Rhett during a recession
representative all me
I got a couple of things but one of them
um King's
on
Rel replies to questions from revenue
estimates percentages the one that gave
us option 6A and 6B yes on
six
B
can be measured against the numbers you
gave us for
um
for option five
in in your presentation
on but 6 a
is against option
four which you didn't use in your
presentation so there's no way to
Compare the numbers
So when you say that we didn't use I
don't know that that's 100 True for
every tax type the the options that we
used in our presentation vary by tax
type yes
um sorry I'm talking about the business
profits tax
right I believe your question was in
general if we could run the scenarios
using those two options for all the
taxes so that's what we did those
scenarios may be more informative for
some taxes versus other taxes depending
on which scenarios we used in our
analysis
yes is is that did you send us all the
options I didn't think so no you asked
if we could also run those options so we
you asked for option 6A and 6B so that's
what we ran and we sent you yes but on
in your presentation where the you just
show us the numbers for the low that you
picked in the high that you correct and
for that one you didn't pick the for the
low the same one that was
on that is 6a which is the one that I
wanted to
what had picked to look at so there's no
way to tell the
if there's any big difference between
the numbers if you'd like we can give
you all of the options we were trying to
not overwhelm you with numbers so that's
why we picked certain options for a high
and a low if you'd like to see all of
them you can but I just yeah didn't want
to clutter everything with additional
information it was just option four
though
the one that you you that I'd asked for
for 6A there's no equivalent number
anywhere if you give me one second I
sorry and what we're talking about is
whether it makes a difference if you
just look at the last three months of
the year to date instead of five months
to decide what's going to happen in the
future
so 6A
is using
actual from prior year year to year yeah
and 6B is using plan
right so 6A
with option five
and six B I believe would correspond
with option four no I was using uh and
you've got it here as uh
or are you using the list that was in
change November to two Okay to January
so sorry the year over year growth okay
so the year over year growth
using
year to date
change as opposed to just the last three
months
um
no it was the last
calculating
it's the sustaining actual revenue from
the first seven months plus sustaining
percentage versus prior year
for the last five months it would be
it was your option for when you
I just want to make sure I read you the
okay so sustaining percent essentially
sustaining percent versus prior year
was 1 billion
one
one two six nine point five like five
okay so these are really they're very
close they're very close
for business taxes in particular yeah
you I believe when you did ask the
question because I wrote it in the
presentation you asked it on that first
slide when we were going through all the
different scenarios so we did apply it
to all the taxes so that you would have
it
Madam chair
are these broad question times yes
please go ahead okay I just wanted to
double check the meals and rentals
um
the we heard the governor's report and
he's at the low end of your range so I
just wanted to double check
um I kind of know the answer your
he
um
they they shared they thought it was
going to flatten out basically because
it had kind of peaked but you didn't do
it that way
well we have a range of it flattening
out to up to five percent growth
um the reason for the five percent
growth
is historically
before you know taking covid kind of out
of the picture
um
it was historically
m r Revenue
grows about five percent year over year
so that would essentially you know what
we've seen in the past couple years has
been obviously more than that
um but we're either going to kind of
stay flat and say that this is the new
normal for m r we're going to stay flat
through the next couple years or m r is
going to continue to grow but not at the
increased rate that we've seen the rate
is going to kind of normalize so that's
the Zero versus the five percent great
that's helpful thank you and just to
follow up on your question from this
morning if I may
um about m r kind of across the state
and whether what you're seeing on the
Seacoast is the same as what maybe other
counties are seeing so in our
presentation that's titled overview of
New Hampshire taxes on slide 26 we show
you the breakdown of meals rentals and
motor vehicles for each of the counties
and if you kind of couple that with the
data that I have at least for February
collections which would be January sales
we continue to see year-over-year growth
in all of our counties for m r with the
exception of Carol and co-oz they're
essentially flat
what is interesting about that is from
slide 26 Carol and koa's are the two
counties with the largest I guess
percent of meals versus rooms their
meals and rooms revenue is almost equal
where if you look say at Rockingham
County 88 of the revenue in Rockingham
County is meals with 11 being brooms so
what I am kind of gathering by that
observation is meals maybe are
continuing to kind of Drive m r revenue
and the rooms is where we might be
seeing more of a stagnation and that's
the disparity among the state counties
thank you that's helpful okay
representative platten yes thank you I'm
going to put you on the spot uh
I could see if you could refute anything
I say okay I could see meals rooms going
up a little bit short run because
vendors are raising their prices to
recover their costs and this we had the
discussion and uh that it's a straight
percentage I could see it going up a
little bit but eventually people hit a
wall and I'm spending it so it goes the
other way and uh I I read the Wall
Street I get vignettes out of that and
again I I've mentioned this before I'm
not using a pun Domino sales is flat uh
in Domino's sales is black because they
see more people eating at home and so I
I do you see a potential for downside in
I think so and we did you write um
representative kind of talk about this
when we were talking about m r generally
obviously if inflation continues to go
up in prices to continue to go up so
long as consumers are willing to still
pay those prices we will see continue to
see an increase in the m r tax because
the tax is paid on the price of the meal
for instance but when that inflation or
those prices reach that point where
consumers start to back away that's when
you know we're potentially going to see
it I don't know that it will turn down
or if it will just stop growing at the
rate that it's been growing
so that is that that's kind of the The
[Laughter]
representative fellows thank you
um on the topic of the meals taxation of
the meals do you have any sense of the
split between fast food places and the
higher end restaurants
I do so actually let me switch to
so this is looking at data for
January revenues which would have been
December activity so December
um sales so
year over year
full service restaurants
were up nine percent
fast food and snack bars were up just
under 17 percent
17.
and that is kind of a trend that we have
seen you know obviously during the
um early months of covid when shutdown
orders were starting to be lifted a lot
of full-service restaurants were not
open but fast food was so a lot of
people gravitated towards fast food then
I think as the pandemic
you know increased different types of
fast food options are now more available
so we do continue to see meals growing
in general during that same period
food as a whole grew just under 12
percent
in total so everyone's growing just
maybe fast food continues to grow still
so I I actually that's that's good I'm
glad to hear that I actually was
thinking in terms of what percentage of
the revenue that comes in is from the
full service versus the fast food
category
uh
uh I can
well here how about this I'll give you
the numbers
um
full service restaurants
in
December of this year generated 14.7
million
fast food generated 7.2 million
representative orrs
thank you madam Karen thanks for taking
my question so overall is the trend in
full-service restaurants up or down flat
I would say up overall okay is there any
the growth rate this month is pretty
consistent with the year-over-year
growth that we saw last month so I think
no
and I'm sure
representative software thank you follow
up
um I'm not a coffee drinker but I'm
amazed at the lines I have three coffee
places near my house and that's all
counting in the fast food
potentially so
we have kind of these broad activity
codes and The Operators when they
request a license from the Department of
Revenue they note what sort of activity
code they fall under so it is likely
um that coffee would probably be under
fast food we also have a bakery category
but unless they're primarily a bakery I
think if you know you're talking about
your drive through Dunkin Donuts
Starbucks that sort of thing they're
representative almie thank you we've got
a fair number of restaurants in my area
that have gone into pickup
which I guess would be classified as
fast food but there are also
full-service restaurants they would
likely still be under full service
because the operator again is going to
designate when they apply for that
license what sort of
activity they perform so if you're
performing sit down and take out it's
likely you're going to call yourself a
full-service restaurant but I think
we've talked previously about how the
pivoting of these full-service
restaurants to those fast food or a
faster takeout type options a lot of
them now have online ordering you know
even a full-service restaurant has the
ability to online order and pick up
that a lot of restaurants did kind of
pivot to that and that has probably
contributed to the increase in sales as
well the convenience
representative plot yes thank you what
difference does it make if we're
categorized under fast food or full
service it's the same percentage it is
it's just a way for us to kind of see
um what's happening within the tax base
um so it's just it at the very basic
level it separates out food rooms and
motor vehicles and then we can drill
down a little bit further as we're doing
now but yes it's all taxed at the same
amount it's all paid by the consumer so
representative Almy thank you I think
when we first started this the idea was
more that lower income people were going
to be eating the fast food and
higher income people were going to be in
the restaurant and that's definition is
disappearing
sure
representative Phelps
I'm just sitting here your lights on
that's why
[Laughter]
okay uh this is your chance to ask lots
of questions unless you want to pick a
one particular column and really drill
down right now go ahead representative
all me
thank you and there's about 11 million
in refunds in interest in dividends year
to date
uh and it's almost doubly amount of
refunds
last year year to date
and the business tax rev refunds are up
a third over the prior year and almost
half of it was in December January
um and but both of them are still the
most they've ever been in 11 years here
to date so so a couple of thoughts on
that one the timing in terms of December
January when returns our calendar year
returns are received on extension
so on a seven month extension they're
typically received in October or
November November corresponding to April
we then have
um
60 days I believe no 90 days to pay the
refund before it hits interest so you'll
often see refunds paid this time of year
because it's the processing of those
Returns on a timely manner and we try
very hard not to pay interest so the the
timing is consistent with those returns
filed on extension in terms of them
being the largest amounts that we've
seen revenue is also the largest that
we've seen so it just kind of correlates
with more Revenue you'd see more refunds
we have looked at it extensively to make
sure that there's not a systematic
problem or there's not you know
something out there that taxpayers were
misinformed and we're making payments
when they shouldn't have that sort of
thing it really just seems to be
um just a higher overall volume there's
always anomalous refunds large you know
one-time refunds but really what we're
seeing is there's just the base is
there's just more of them there are more
taxpayers than we've ever seen there's
more money than that we've ever seen so
representative Ames
um
I'm going to ask you this if you look at
the business taxes
and you're high and lows and you you go
low all the way through
the three years and if you do the same
for the highs
the difference is a lot of money
um close to 200 million I think
um and
what I
want to ask is uh is a whether there's
any new information that's come to your
attention our new ideas about this
that push you in one direction or the
other or whether you're you're inclined
to advise us that
one side or another of this is more
understood
um
the more information is going to come
next month which is it's hard to hear I
know
um
once we start seeing returns in March
that will help us a little bit more
understand you know where things are
trending
um I would say in terms of any new
information I know
um Phil Sutton copied us on a response
to the committee about some research he
had kind of put together in terms of
just general economic Trends and what
various sources are saying and I you
know I think all of his sources kind of
lined up as well with the range
understanding that the range does
produce a large range of dollar amounts
um
I don't think we have any more
information at this point it's probably
forthcoming
um the only I guess
reference point is that
it looks as though February business tax
revenues are coming in a little bit
lower than plan in a little bit lower
than prior year again February tends to
be a smaller month and some of that can
be a bit of a timing difference where we
may have either last year received late
payments from the December January time
frame or early payments from March or
April but I mean that is the first time
that we've seen business taxes kind of
not knocking plan and prior year out of
the water so that might give me a little
bit of hesitation but again I wouldn't
put a lot of weight in the February
numbers where plan is 21.3 million and
we're talking over a billion in Revenue
so just the materiality of it but the
fact that we're a little bit below prior
year and a little bit below plan
um yeah I saw that I'm sorry I saw that
February
um whatever it is and um wondered about
it
um and it's too small as you just said
to take anything away but I I guess one
piece of the information that I don't
think had come out yet was the estimates
and whether there's any change in the
estimates Trend that might be picked up
there uh you know
I don't think so yeah we shouldn't go
too far with February I I agree with you
on that yeah
representative elderly I'm Albert
I'm sorry thank you madam chair sorry
just
since we're down in the noise already is
it possible that any of that drop
is related to weather and particularly
say lack of snow up in the mountains so
um ski stuff
in turn that would we would likely see
that in our m r Revenue
um and you're right those two counties
that I mentioned where um they were
performing a little bit lower than last
year where kolas and Carol to counties
that would benefit from a snowier winter
um so that definitely could be part of
it now of course we're into a week where
it seems like it's going to snow every
other day so winter has finally arranged
representative Platt I know you put a
tremendous amount of thought into all of
these Revenue projections high and low
but that was done how long ago these
Road numbers for by the dra couple of
months so we update them every month
what James referred to this morning the
revenue estimates of ours that he used
to produce the governor's budget were
revenues through December given the
timing and then we updated them through
January when we came to you and we will
update them later this week to go
through February as well I guess by
basic question is you've got all the
data you can get so is there any is your
gut telling you that there's any one of
these Revenue estimates that's going to
be below your low or higher than your
representative fellows so I have um the
questions that I was asking about the
meals I have the same kind of question
for the business taxes because my
recollection is that
there's just a few 16 or so corporations
pay the vast majority of the business
taxes so if you're seeing upward or
downward Trends if you could tell us
about those big ones versus the other
ones anything along that line
so you are correct that the majority of
business tax payer business tax revenue
comes in from a few taxpayers
and
those of you that have kind of been on
the committee during the past few years
especially during covid
it remained true that the majority of
Revenue still came from a few taxpayers
it's just those types of taxpayers may
have changed as certain businesses or
industries did better during the coveted
pandemic than others so we talked
um when we were Revenue estimating last
time about you know retail did really
well right people still wanted to buy
things during covet obviously medical
supplies medical devices did well but
restaurants or the hospitality industry
during those initial phases of covid
certainly were hurt by it so we still
see that small number at the top it is
typically a variety of Industries but
sometimes they kind of come and go based
on what's happening in the economy at
that time
I don't have the same activity level
data that I do for m r for business
taxes
would it make sense to try to attack
something like meals and rooms now I
would rather go for something more
stable that we could probably just
throwing out there while we have the
commissioner here I don't know pick pick
whatever you want tobacco tobacco might
be a great topic
when we think about tobacco any let's go
to Tobacco see if we have any remaining
I will just note with tobacco if I may
Madam chair the you know the ranges are
um are pretty small you know we're we're
looking at looking at page four of your
of your worksheet
um 217 to
222.8 so a little over five million
dollar you know spread not the 200
million that we're looking at with
business taxes
um so those are tighter ranges you know
the governor
um is kind of right in that middle of
the range for 23 a little closer to the
higher end in 24 and 25 but again those
those ranges are pretty tight it's a
tax that we feel like we know generally
what's going to happen there
representative Madam chair all
throughout a straw poll and see if it
crumbles in Hay
okay
hold off on that please uh
representative Almy has a question yes I
just want you go down to the low with
five percent the next year and then only
three percent the year after what's that
so the five percent
the negative five percent is kind of a
more aggressive normalizing of tobacco
where we have started to see kind of
this downturn occurring as we mentioned
potentially as folks shift away from
traditional cigarettes into other
tobacco products
um and so the minus five percent kind of
assumes that Trend continues
um that we've been seeing we've been
about minus five to minus seven percent
year over year
um throughout this year so kind of
assuming that Trend continues and then
representative about me as you know the
minus three percent is just kind of the
traditional year-over-year decrease in
in the tobacco tax that we were seeing
um in the Years leading up to covid
um so it's just a little bit more of an
aggressive decline in the first year and
then kind of moving back to that more
historic Norm
yeah Madam chair how much would that
have to do with
um the adaptation of the Massachusetts
Use users of Menthol that is another
potential part of it right we saw a
spike in revenues here in New Hampshire
that have been documented when
Massachusetts ban methylated products a
lot of people came to New Hampshire to
buy those products some may still be
coming here some may have switched to a
different product that they then can now
purchase in Massachusetts again so it
could be some of that as well where
they've decided that for whatever reason
they don't need to come to New Hampshire
to buy those products anymore and so
that could be contributing to the
decline as well
representative Southworth uh thank you
um is there an explanation for yours
being like five million more
um no I think it's just the result of
producing a range yeah
um he it we go through a very similar
exercise with the governor where we
produce ranges and so
um I think his amount just ended up kind
of some he picked somewhere in the
middle of the range and we're giving you
the rain the same range or a very
similar range okay so there's no
specific reason thank you
foreign
Pole
I believe so yeah okay
um I believe the agency I believe the
agency could be wrong or either way so
I'm I'm suggesting split the difference
between agency low and high
for tobacco which would be 219
uh for uh
219.9 is fine
uh which which the governor had but the
214 4 and 24 and 211 4 and 25 which is
about splitting the difference
between uh the agency's high and low
all right can we restate that wait do we
have a second I'm sorry
sure go ahead
thank you madam chair um yeah I was just
look just looking at these numbers
quickly agency high for 23 24 and 25 is
the same number if you're seeing a
degradation in tobacco why pick this the
high to be the same and not having a
declining high so again it was just a
result of kind of producing a range so
um in many taxes you'll see the range
kind of goes from Flat to growth in
tobacco it's going the other way so we
may find that the decline that we've
seen over the past year or so those that
have switched are gonna have switched
those that have gone back to purchasing
their products in Massachusetts have
gone back to purchasing their products
in Massachusetts and then we're just
going to kind of continue Where We Are
it's probably more likely that we're
going to continue to fall but you know
it could be that you know this is kind
of the bottom and we're just going to
stay here
all right any more discussion or do we
want to review what those numbers are
one more time I'd like
to okay so uh column C under tobacco
fy23 I said 219. FY 23 I said 219 9
which is the governor's estimate it's
about splits theirs but for fy24 I split
the agency high and low and came up with
214 4.
and for 25 I split the agency higher low
can we get a show of hands for everyone
all right I think it's almost unanimous
let me just see anyone who's opposed
one okay so it would be 14 to 1 to take
Madam chair yes representative
Southworth I'd like to continue and do
meals and rooms because I just feel like
we just got a lot of detailed
information about it so I mean I think
we have time to go forward on that a
um wondering how are we doing for time
here
yeah representative you said did you say
you have to leave soon too yeah I don't
know if we have time okay
yeah I'm just concerned because that
might take a half an hour and I have no
at least one person who has to leave and
that would be a bummer yeah thank you I
was thinking of easier ones like
requested more data from the insurance
department which they will be providing
tomorrow so to be able to hear that data
I think we should probably hold off on
that one liquor may be something we
could look at although the commissioner
doesn't do those numbers right so
um but we could take a look at that uh
Chris do you wanna
okay you you did receive a full packet
from liquor
in addition I had sent an email out with
some information from liquor I think
there was some questions as to why
um Liquors numbers were higher than the
governors in 24 and 25 and then why the
governor was higher in 23 than liquor I
think you heard this morning from
director Gary that they the governor
stands by the 135 number that they've
suggested not the 130 that the
um
liquid commission has suggested for 23
and then the difference for 24 and 25 in
terms of what liquor presented to you
and what the governor had according to
the Liquor Commission related to um uh
pay raise they took money out for the
pay raise if you do that it brings them
down to closer to what the governor
recommended
my notes say that the governor's office
said that they're actually the same
number in 2023
one was 135 one was 130 but the 130
includes the transfer to
okay so basically 130 would be the
appropriate number or
so
I think what the agency provided you is
that 130 would be the transfer to the
general fund right okay so 130 is the
right number okay
for 2023.
representative all me
the governor was
wasn't he using the same
same idea of transfer to the general
fund
yeah
but
I
would be quite willing to assume that
the agency knows more about their
numbers than the governor does but
uh representative Platt I try a straw
here I can get shot down no big deal but
I'll try it
um for one at 130 for fiscal 23 which is
the agency's high and low
and I think the governor says it's the
same his as high because he didn't take
the stuff out it needs to be taken out
135 9 for 2024 and 135.6 for 20
135 9 135 9 for 2024 which is the agency
hired low
and then 135 6 for 2025 which is the
agency high and low
all right I have different numbers than
so representative Sanborn you may be
looking at older numbers
so that the 135 9 and the 135 6 are the
numbers that were adjusted by removing
the amounts they would need for the pay
raise it's February 26. hand it out
okay uh do I have a second on that first
of all
representative Southworth seconds okay
all right and comments representative
elmy oh just one more question to Chris
on
The Liquor Commission had to transfer
over beyond the 5 million I think that
they were originally allocated anything
more that Health and Human Services
needed for expanded medicaid
uh is that ending in in July
so um
they don't anticipate in a further
transfer this year in 23. right now
just over 18 million dollars
the budgeted amount was the 11.5 million
which is related to the 5 transfer to
the drug and alcohol fund
and then there was an additional 7
million point two transfer that is a
result of short
um the granted Advantage fund being
short to pay its bills so there's two
statutes in play here but um the second
statute which is RSA 126aa which is the
granted Advantage Medicaid expansion
fund
um they don't they be an HHS does not
anticipate any further money needed for
that this year
they also don't anticipate going into
the out years potentially needing it if
the law stays current because they
expect the roles to come down on
Medicaid which has been what's driving
some of the the needed revenue for
liquor
but it's it's a crapshoot in terms of if
for some reason the the case loads stay
up which isn't anticipated but if they
were to stay up they might need to do it
and the law allows for that but it's not
what's planned for it's the just the
five percent transfer but if that showed
up before July 1
they would put that would go into the
Surplus statement rather than into the
okay we have a motion that's been a
seconded uh any more discussion on the
okay all of those in favor of accepting
looks like everyone anyone opposed
all right it's now two
um why don't we stop now
and uh
tomorrow we're on for 10.
do we want to try to make it in because
last week the storm that they said was 6
to 12 inches turned out to be a lot less
or do what do we want to do what do
everyone jump in and tell me your
thoughts
we're under time pressure I'd say try to
make it up here and see what we can do
if we have to break early because it's
continuous snowing we can break early
yeah man
um representative
yeah the
I think the storm is supposed to start
at midnight
so hopefully most of it will be over by
the time we might break early no
we have a oh representative spilsbury
and I'm sorry that's not consistent with
the forecast I saw
but it depends what part of the state
you're into right three to five four to
eight Etc is the ranges I do not intend
to drive in tomorrow morning the
forecast indicates the snow will start
around 1 to 3 A.M and it'll continue
heavy through the morning so I don't
intend to drive in the snow I would love
to come on Wednesday when it's 43
degrees and sunny and stay as long as it
takes
well if we one moment and then we'll
come to you and everyone else
um if we so Wednesday is our deadline so
if we just do that we can come in at 10
and stay till we're done the other
option is we could start tomorrow later
but we could lose the presentations if
we end up you know because they can only
get rescheduled so much so we might lose
the presentations and we might have to
ask them to email us their thoughts and
wisdom
if you're okay with that we could maybe
start at one tomorrow how would who
most maybe not okay
um Madam chair representative fellows
yeah I just wanted to say that where I
live is right in the epicenter of the
four to eight range like right on why
they say eight so I would feel like a
lot better I was going to suggest 11 but
and the later the better would work for
me yeah because I really do want to come
in but it doesn't even doesn't sound
very safe to try to drive in at nine
okay representative Elmer I'm looking at
the National Weather Service forecast
thank you rather than just the other one
and um the uh according to this the
percentage of precipitation or the
chance of precipitation starting at uh
about 10 in the morning is 87 and
doesn't drop below 70 until about five
so it's supposed to be pretty awful
smack in the middle of all the potential
work time
and then early representative Doucette
how about called the chair at 7 A.M you
make the call and let us know via email
or whatever and we'll take a picket pick
a look at 701 and go from there
well in the end we could make a decision
and the speaker might say this whole
place is shut down so we won't have a
choice so uh other comments
representative fellows so I I just it
might be good to check with the people
who are going to give us the
presentations to make sure you know
well representative Southworth thank you
I think the other thing would be on
Wednesday
um just to dig in and do it and there
may be other questions later on and as
you said we can make adjustments later
on but we really need to get the first
group of estimates done Wednesday
I agree with that and I honestly don't
want to get too bogged down with more
presentations I'm a little bit worried
about that because if we end up like
today we spend you know a solid amount
of time
you know I just want to eat up all of
our day Wednesday we have a lot of
information
we can write numbers How would how would
the committee feel about being emailed
from Department of Employment Security
and the insurance department I'm sure
they've already prepared their
presentation if they were to email it to
us yesterday so our homework for
tomorrow would be to read it but how
does that sound
sounds good be a favor to them too
but
so so is it the intent of the committee
to ask the two agencies just to provide
their written
testimonial slides that would be emailed
to the members but we wouldn't
reschedule for them to actually come
before the committee
I think that's what we're leaning to
representative and if there's a question
that we have after reading that we can
email them back
yep
so
when is your deadline do you have to go
to the finance committee at five o'clock
on Wednesday
uh no but it is my verbal commitment to
the chair of finance and to the speaker
that we would have it done on Wednesday
so I would intend to but that's vague so
yes oh wait wait no if we wanted to stay
here and I could you know bring us some
wine and we'll stay till seven I don't
know uh but I'm sure most of you want to
have a home life representative Ames
well thank you um yeah it's just gonna
chime in since I hadn't um that I think
uh makes a lot of sense to uh
to not come here on Tuesday get the
written materials that we can get and
think about all this stuff and come in
on Wednesday and get the job done
yeah
yeah I think that's the consensus then
let's uh we'll cancel tomorrow I don't
know how to do that officially because
it's on the calendar
oh I'll talk to Karen okay Karen can
hopefully send out something so we will
cancel tomorrow hopefully you're all
safe at home and not driving and then
but doing your homework doing your
thinking preparing for Wednesday for
decision time and we'll be here
Wednesday at 10 A.M
and would you like the ra to be
available Wednesday or is it okay if
they don't come back we would love okay
to have them here that would be fabulous
if you can thank you thank you that is
the status wonderful Lindsay shooting
daggers at me from behind me because we
keep
as you can tell we keep uh punting on
right so yeah we would love to have you
here thank you okay good we have a good